guys if you didn't know we are touring
america
here all the places we're going to oh my
god i love it all of these places so
guys again head on over to
thetrashtastictor.com links in the
description below and uh for all of you
americans we will see you all there so
what's the opinion on uh skipping
cutscenes absolutely not i skipped like
all cuts here
we're gonna have a first guest walk off
we're gonna make history today
[Music]
welcome to this episode of trash taste
i'm back with the boys gone and joe
usual and today we have a very special
guest rosie d sung juan what's up how
you doing doing good yeah you're so
relaxed already like you've been here
for hours yeah yeah you've just sunken
into that i've always been on this show
just in the background it's nice being
there someone who who has a deep voice
as well yeah it's comforting i feel like
i get do did you get deeper when you're
around someone else with a deeper voice
oh no i do yeah i mean yeah i mean yeah
you just go like the audio listeners are
really confused
by the time we end this podcast only
whales will be able to understand
what's going on
but no i mean uh i think yeah you've
been a requested guest for a long time
yeah because obviously i feel like
you're in the same kind of circles right
it's kind of like niche animation the
anime circle yeah
i saw that i saw that clip of uh how you
were being harassed online
yeah and i was like i mean
yeah the next time i go to japan i guess
which will be in like five years if i'm
lucky
uh but no yeah when conor reached out to
be like hey can you be on i was like
hell yeah um
it's been a long time coming yeah yeah
definitely have you ever been to japan
before i have i've been there twice i
went there
uh
god i don't know time anymore but like
maybe i think it was like right before
pandemic maybe like the year before
right
and the year before that so like i did a
trip to korea and japan
and was in korea for a week than tokyo
for a week um and that was with like my
wife and my my mom and my brother and
then the next year around the exact same
time both fall time i went to tokyo
again with some friends right
i would love to go outside of tokyo like
you know osaka kyoto like yeah yeah but
mainly i've just done tokyo what'd you
do when you were there
oh you know weeb [ __ ]
well like the first time i went it was
mainly
just my mom and uh was there you know we
did a lot of temples and yeah
traditional stuff traditional stuff
although i did take her to akihabara
and she was like what the hell was this
did you say
yes
did you take her to a maid cafe i did
not uh because i have dignity but uh
i um was
so
like it was very surreal seeing her
react to
um because it's a huge it's crazy yeah
yeah
let's see what else did i do uh like
knocking on broadway
yeah yeah
yeah
i'm a big disney guy so tokyo disneysea
um
uh other than that like just
going around like um different areas
like ikebukuro and stuff like that and
yeah just checking stuff out did you
play uh the love life games while you
were in there no i didn't what i did end
up doing was uh a ton of crane games
okay
i ended up getting like tons of [ __ ]
through the crane games yeah that became
my thing nice
yeah did you play against each other
yeah you got a chance yeah yeah i hear
you're really good uh
i'm not good i'm just tenacious well
he's he's only good because he's done
like six videos yeah
way more money than anyone should have
spent about like six thousand dollars
now on crane games you would hope that
you would be good you literally like pay
to win right
what is the best thing you wanted uh
green game oh definitely um i got this
uh it was like a
really nicely made lucario plush okay
that's holding like uh like one of the
pokemon fruits but it's like you know
when you get a plush sometimes you pick
it out of the thing you're like whoa
this is just anemic i feel like there's
there's stuff inside but there's like
it's like they didn't care where it was
yeah like the stuffing is all over the
place it's just a really really nice
quality plush and i would easily like
see it at the pokemon store or whatever
for like 60 bucks 50 bucks yeah it's
really nice and you can get it for like
20 pretty reasonably nice if you're good
yeah now even if you're bad you can just
be like sumo yeah
come over like right right because they
don't know you know the staff don't know
how long you've been playing for they're
polite you know they just they just
assume you're not taking the piss and
not calling them over after one yeah
which i don't do yeah which i'm sure
they'll respond to willingly anyway they
would like if you just took one shot
yeah and maybe actually because they
they'd know if you've moved it a bunch
right yeah with certain claws they don't
know yeah yeah because if you pick up
something and it just flops over
somewhere they're not going to know it's
your first time yeah yeah with the ones
where you got to shimmy it yeah suck
yeah
you can't choose them you have to just
do it but that they'd know if you would
yeah
now that i've been in japan for a while
i'd like i was never like deeply into
the crane game culture just because like
obviously you want to win the prize but
i feel like you get like cooler
figurines and cooler accessories just by
buying it you know
yeah but there are some exclusive stuff
that is only for crane games right but
you you can buy it because yeah but like
do you think it's like do you think it's
like cooler than what you can actually
find in store and like other places i'll
say this for me like for me i don't ever
buy plushies ever right that's not
something i do actually that's true but
in a crane game i'm like but if i win
this
then it's [ __ ] great
i can get behind the plushie i remember
like winning the chainsaw man plushie in
your video that was actually
legitimately cool that's probably like
the only thing that i kept oh i've got
the pen pen as well oh yeah oh yeah
cause i i feel like crane game figurines
like
you know you know like they look like
crane game figurines you know they're
pretty basic yeah they're very figurines
are okay i do make i don't know if you
do this but when i pursue a crane game
it does have to be something at least
relevant to my interests yeah like i do
have a friend who like
just does them to like get like victory
yeah he just gives away the [ __ ] but for
me it's like it's got to be something i
like actually care about getting
something you actually want to keep yeah
yeah if it was me on my own no videos or
no cameras or anything then yeah that
would help i would do it but on camera
you're like well i got to win stuff
so i don't want to play the machines
that are hard yeah so i'm going to play
the ones that i know i can win and then
sometimes you get a good plush and you
get it in an amount of turns you're like
this was a steal i got this for a steal
yeah i got this in 10 and this
definitely costs 20 bucks in retail yeah
i'm a genius i'm a master i'm gaming the
system yeah
that's what it feels amazing
you had a fun time you won and then you
also have a prize for cheaper than you
would have paid for it yeah yeah but you
also never would have bought that
product yes because so because you've
done the crane game video with conor as
well how long did it take for you to
just kind of like be [ __ ] sick of it
because like the first 15 minutes i
remember i think it was like after half
an hour i was just like how is this
gonna like it was a great video but like
i remember drinks film during filming
i'm like this is gonna be like because
it's like every like 15 like 20 minutes
you think you're starting to get it yeah
and then something happens when you're
just like never mind i don't know how to
do this now
yeah i know nothing yeah we just give
people a budget and it normally takes
like three hours of playing crane games
sure and uh that's a long time to play
it's like a long time because after the
first hour yeah like you said you start
to just start to get really miserable
yeah yeah you're also carrying all the
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta
remove because we have like a suction
cup to attach to it yeah it's just it's
a whole ordeal unless you're chris and
you only win one thing yeah yeah yeah so
some people not very good we had the
only person who actually enjoyed doing
it and wanted to keep doing it was cajo
right but calhoun
yeah she's really good yeah she's good
at them as well yeah but like i've been
excited to have you on because normally
like with our previous guests right
there's been this like joke where the
guests are just like oh we're gonna talk
about anime and we kind of like look at
each other and laugh right because uh we
generally talk a lot less about anime
than people think that we talk about it
but
you loki have like a [ __ ] amazing
taste in anime
like i don't know like i just i just
gotta say man i just i can't remember
what video it was where like you had to
like say what your favorite anime were
but i remember you going down the list
and i'm like damn you got some good
[ __ ] shows
you were raiding waifus i think
which one yeah out of the mini videos i
think yeah yeah i i watch i was like
okay okay yeah it's got a good taste
remember when this guy busted that oh
yeah i really like legends of the
galactic heroes that's that's that's how
you that's
i have seen
70 episodes i've still got like the last
last few hours to go through but yeah
it's it's [ __ ] incredible it's great
it's amazing and you rarely get you kind
of look so lost right now but uh i've
voiced in like one of the
dubs or something you in the in the new
one right yeah me too yeah yeah i feel
like every everyone digs
there's so many characters there's so
many verses like i can't get every voice
actor what did your guy do in it uh he
was uh i think he was someone in a bar
overhearing something and talking about
covert uh
it was no it was two of them they're
from different factions and they were
arguing but like very discreetly were
you on yongwin lee's side or reinhardt
i was on the one where you don't know
[ __ ] about the characters you play
i rocked up and i was like why don't you
watch the shows you voiced
legend of the gladiator is an exception
it's too [ __ ] long
it's good though it's it's it's only
really i mean i mean even i haven't
finished the original yeah but i've
really i think the remake is also really
good i hear it's good yeah i haven't
seen it i haven't seen the remake i just
realized you hadn't told the people what
you do oh yeah he's probably introduced
himself
i feel like most people know you but i
mean
you know discrepancy
uh yeah i'm sung one show uh i go by pro
zd online uh i do youtube i'm a voice
actor it's kind of
right he's kind of you're underselling
yourself yeah he's voiced in so many
cool [ __ ]
you blew up on vine right yeah yeah and
then you're killing it you also have the
world record for getting banned on tick
tock
i have no idea i was on it for about a
week uh and then uh
i just woke like my wife texted me
because i was out of town and she's like
why are you banned on tick tock i was
like what do you mean why am i banned
and i was banned on tick tock and so i
think i scared them off with the tweet
in the video that i made right
where i was like i don't care if i'm
unbanned but this is [ __ ] dumb and
yeah
immediately after that i was unmanned
with no explanation as to why was it
people were uploading a lot of your
content to tick tock that would that
would have been happening for years
before uh so
i don't know if it was like people
flagging me or
because i think because you could swear
on tick tock right yeah yeah like i
don't think there's like restrictions on
that so it might have just been like
flagging or something or maybe they
really i mean at the time it wouldn't
let me upload a profile picture yeah so
maybe they thought i was a really
convincing fake or something
but
back now i guess yeah so my god all
youtubers try to figure out tiktok yeah
right have you used that [ __ ] app
every now and then yeah every now and
again it's a nightmare
it feels weird because like i use i use
youtube shorts way more often because at
least like it's i know what my tastes
are and it's like garnet towards my
taste tiktok it's like it's a bit scary
to put that much of yourself into just
this [ __ ] algorithm to be like okay
i'm gonna i'm just you are going to let
a computer figure out your entire life
personality by swiping yeah that's
that's that's basically tick tock right
and i'm just like it's like impressive
how good the algorithm is but it's also
like scary too very scary yeah yeah so i
mean we post like clips of like our
podcast and everything on tick tock but
aside from that we don't make original
content for tick-tock
yeah
are you uh do you browse it pretty often
or you
what made you go on it
um
i think for me it was something where
i wanted something that i could just
have no pressure with yeah um although
everything i do with [ __ ] online i
don't do well and i just do i just do
[ __ ] so it's like but i guess with
at least with youtube
uh i have to like have some semblance of
like okay i cannot just do
board game reviews that nobody gives a
[ __ ] about i have to like sometimes do a
video that maybe other people will watch
so it's like a balancing act for me
right right uh okay one for me one for
them like
you know make sure that make sure that
youtube would choke about it like yeah
yeah and make sure the production values
look like they're from 2007. like that's
yeah that's my channel like
i don't i'm looking at all this
equipment i'm like wow
this is what real youtubers do i don't
know anything uh
you know i use my iphone to record my
videos i i i got i had a feeling like
but that's part of the charm right
that's part of the charm because yeah
the charm
no there's definitely demographic that
misses like the old school youtube vibe
and style where it's just filmed on it
yeah see that's not a that's not like me
being like this is a smart decision it's
like i'm very lazy yeah i was gonna say
no very very lazy
uh that's the easiest way to do it and
then that's it
um so going back to tick tock uh yeah i
think it was just like another avenue of
like
i i don't care how well tick-tock does
yeah like at all i have no stakes like
if it does well that's great if not i
don't care because i you know i'm just
brand new on it right yeah so i mean
it's doing like pretty pretty good like
like it's but for me what's important is
that i'm having fun with it you know
it's something where
i'm actually inspired now okay i can
just put out like a fun silly little
20 second video and not have to worry
about oh is it like up to the standards
yeah whatever blah blah blah so that's
basically what i've been doing yeah i
mean like your content seems to be like
very you know if i would have to say
you'd see it would seem like it would be
suited for tick tock because like very
short form
like
short form
high intensity like skits and
like that and like i still plan on doing
skits for the channels specifically yeah
um because i also
cannot stand that you have to film it
vertically like i'm so old like i'm just
like
i gotta film it like i'm uh it's gross
even vine was like a box at least this
is like
[ __ ] anyway so
i i'm still planning to do skits and
also editing on
tiktok is such a nightmare i know i know
you can upload stuff to it yeah i'm lazy
all right again
super lazy so it's like okay if i can
just do it in the app i'll just do it
and post it or whatever yeah that's like
the purpose of tick tock stuff but then
for regular skits it's like okay i'll
actually edit it myself and yeah you
know make it a little nicer
um
yeah whereas for
if i just have a silly little idea i can
just do it in like 20 seconds like i
just could post it out there and yeah
have fun with it right because like i
remember you saying you still recording
your phone and everything yeah and you
never really have like tried to like
market yourself or you know make that
kind of content but like i remember when
you switched over to vine to youtube you
kind of started making these skits where
it was just like very short skits but
the thumbnail was just like your face
and the title was just like uh exactly
what it says on the tin kind of like
titling and i remember that was like so
unique at the time for youtube because
everything was like getting like
pristine and proper with like our
marketing and you came along and it was
just like it's just a guy with like his
face and then somehow that just became
the meta everyone started doing this
lowercase titles yeah lowercase i've so
noticed that lowercase titles
do you know i might have told you this
but do you know why those thumbnails are
the way they are why why you know since
the channel has since i've had that
channel like since 2006 like
you know how it generates three random
thumbnails yeah i just picked the one i
like best
i have never
made a single custom thumbnail video
are you stupid i'm like yeah i'm stupid
and lazy like for me
when i was younger i always thought it
was fun because back then you couldn't
make a thumbnail yeah yeah i was like
it's funny oh like which one am i going
to use and which one is you know the
best one yeah and
for
god how long has been now like 15 years
right
i've never
i've never noticed i've never made a
customer i see what the three thumbnails
are
and i
picked the one that looks the most well
but sometimes with those three auto
generator thumbnails like there are some
videos where i've uploaded where it's
just like wow these all look horrible
right it doesn't matter
dude i'm just like okay uh i i uh had
youtube gave me like a manager once you
guys have a
manager yeah it's [ __ ] anyway
so they
like we're like oh yeah you're here as a
manager and i'm like okay and he didn't
understand me at all he was like he
he pulled up like a video he's like so
what's going on in this thumbnail i'm
like
i don't know
this is for you because i figure out
what the [ __ ] yeah because it's like one
of the board game reviews which like you
know
i will say the board game reviews are
entirely for me because for those of you
who aren't aware i'm a huge board game
fan yeah yeah um and like people are
like
you know these videos are only getting
like this many views i'm like yeah no
[ __ ] like i'm not an idiot i know how
numbers work
but for me it's like i just you know
enjoy making them and they're just like
a little side project yeah yeah he was
like looking at him it's just like a
board game on a table maybe my hand is
like covering half of it because it's
one of the [ __ ] thumbnails he's like
he's like what's good what
you know you can make custom thumbnails
i was like i don't do that he's like
he's like what
what do you mean you don't do i'm like
no i don't want to do that it's like i
would recommend i was like i'm not gonna
and then like and then maybe like a
couple months later they're like okay
you're not on you don't have a partner i
mean
i just threw the talent yeah they were
like this guy doesn't
like i'm done i give up he like pulled
up this like
there was this whole powerpoint
presentation he was like you know these
videos is like a skit do really well and
these videos board game review don't do
well and i'm like
i know
um it's like did you know if you do more
videos like this i'm like
oh really
thank you so much you're really very
very useful
um
so for me it's been like
i've been very stubborn because uh
youtube was like an accident right right
for me it's always been voice i'm very
very very passionate about voice acting
very serious about it you know take that
very seriously with youtube i don't take
it seriously at all and it's
managed to work out like i know it won't
last forever and i know that you know
but even i mean i don't know like it's
still
working you know yeah yeah exactly so i
think for me it's always been like
instead of uh going down a path where i
hate what i'm doing or am not at least
enjoying what i'm doing it's like i'll
just
stop doing i'm just gonna do it until
like
literally no one gives a [ __ ] and then
hopefully by then i'll be doing other
things
yeah yeah i mean like was voice acting
always like the final end goal for you
oh yeah yeah that was since um
like high school right yeah high school
that was like my dream right like to one
day maybe be able to do it yeah uh so
and a lot of people might have heard the
story but like the tl dr is like uh my
my whole internet journey was i started
on tumblr actually did audio posts those
got really like big
the goofy covers right some movie
covers and things like that yeah that
led to vine and then vine went really
big yeah and then vine led to the
youtube channel getting really big yeah
so it just those were the steps but that
was like
um 2012
uh
i just graduated from college right and
i was like i don't know how the what the
[ __ ] i'm going to do um
so i did made the tumblr a voice acting
templar did one post every day every
single day for
like three four years or whatever
that eventually developed like a
following and then
that's what i uh attribute all my
success to on in the online spaces of
that right and actually even the voice
acting space because i was practicing
voice acting right right um prior to
vine and even before people knew who i
was that's what i was talking about like
independent like video games and yeah
you start getting referred to other
directors and stuff so right um
yeah a lot of people
they
even now to this day they'll be like oh
my god brosie dude's in a game i'm like
i have been in like
100 things over the past like
eight years like i don't know but you
know but it's fine people some people
know you for one thing or yeah yeah yeah
um
so yeah that's that was
where everything it was just me sort of
sitting down and be like
i want to do voice acting i don't know
how i'm going to get into the industry
yeah you just kind of make [ __ ] on your
own and
you know yeah and that's what the advice
i always give to people who are like how
do you become a voice actor it's like
just start making [ __ ]
practice every single day yeah practice
every day
yeah take classes make [ __ ] put yourself
out there meet other people and
because like a lot of people like you
know including you and like you know my
age my age
that generation of voice actors
all start kind of started that way like
i just made stuff online whether it was
fan dubs or these things yeah
[ __ ] posts exactly and now
you know we're ice ice whenever i see
people nowadays they're like who's this
newcomer i'm like no i know who that is
that guy's been like you know yeah he's
been grinding and like you know yeah
he's been working for like years like
he's not a newcomer at all he's just
like finally getting his you know just
like you know his uh
success that he deserves yeah
you see from like the old times you're
like oh yeah he's killing it now yeah
it's it's weird for me as well because i
even though i've never been a voice
actor or tried voice acting uh i've
always been aware of like i call it like
the va generation yes where it's like
there was this like voice acting board
called like the voice acting alliance
where everyone would post some fines and
find like new fandub projects bridging
projects and i see a lot of those names
that i used to see on the board now
actually voicing like real anime or just
like [ __ ] killing it in some other
fields on youtube or something yeah
obviously like people are you know
they're always going to need new talent
yeah and who better than the people
who've been doing it since they're like
15 online yeah like
a [ __ ] ton of yeah it's in this one
specialized field it's all just level
grinding right yeah level grinding and
grinding and then just getting to a
point where you're ready yeah um pretty
much yeah just trying to get the the
requirements you joke but everything in
my life is just like a list of
achievements
like i want to play all these board
games why not eat all these restaurants
like yeah yeah well i find it funny
because like i remember back in the day
there was definitely like this air of
just like
look at these kids trying to get into
anime by doing fan dubs online [ __ ] yeah
no you got to go to like you got to be
in the industry man these kids are just
playing around so it's actually just
gratifying just to see everyone actually
[ __ ] people actually succeeding after
putting in the grind because it you know
it might have been like fan work and fan
dubs but you get like it's that's your
experience
yeah um
uh sarah jane sherman who's a very
well-known casting director she recently
tweeted
uh very similar like advice like yeah
just start making stuff like i i've seen
people make tick tocks of them like
doing voices for their fish and it's
like
i mean you laugh but it's like that's
actual you yet you are demonstrating
yeah
so i always encourage people like yeah
just make [ __ ] and
yeah see what happens and just you know
one thing i've noticed is that i don't
know if it's if you guys feel this on
your end but you feel like having a
social media presence even as an actor
is like as like
more and more important
now as like than it used to be because
it's certainly important or getting more
important now on the japanese side of
things oh interesting yeah like some of
the top voice actors now have such a
massive like social media presence and
there's a lot of people who get to know
them not just from the roles that they
do but also from just like what they do
on twitter or like instagram or like
even on youtube
i swear some some voice actors here say
yeah it's really important others say no
i don't think so what do you think
i have an answer but i'm curious what
your thoughts are i think it's
undeniable that having a
large presence would would put your name
kind of in the face of more people
whether it would lead to you actually
getting more stuff i feel like that's up
to you and how much work you're putting
in yeah sure sure but i feel like it's
definitely gonna put you in front of
people more yeah i think that's that's
fair to say yeah definitely i think just
like now that everyone is using it no no
there's no correction
did i have to currently tell you
the free friend of the question was like
you told me yeah
it's the interviewer like tone like i'll
judge uh i think i have a more
complicated
like answer for it because i do agree
with you that um
having a bigger following just people
knowing who you are is that's good right
yeah uh whether it's for networking
whether it's for
just even getting introduced to things
or whatever it is yeah is good
um but uh for
i think there can also be
kind of a
stigma oh yeah towards um
it's like the idea of like oh you you're
a youtuber and you're trying to be a
voice actor like there's definitely been
i mean i will say one there was one
project i recorded for
uh
and then the i was working with one
director the other director
found out i was like a big youtuber he's
like you put a [ __ ] youtuber and uh
took me out really really yeah yeah this
happened
i won't say the name of it but uh
also that guy was a [ __ ] anyway but
like i never worked with him but i've
heard he's just a [ __ ] so anyway
yeah that was one instance where um i
went in i recorded uh and was i lost the
part because this guy was like that's
[ __ ] up yeah so i mean that's a that
was only one time right um still the
fact that i even happened yeah it's
still
it's still very i mean and you you'll
you'll see like um on twitter on twitter
there will be like backlash like oh so
and so
they just put them in because they're
and it's like
no like
so and so has been you know working hard
towards that goal for a long time and
it's like you know
also if any
um anyone who actually gives a [ __ ]
about the art that they're making yeah
they want the performances to be good
right yeah so they're not gonna hire
someone just for
the clout just for the cloud right
that's something you're gonna see in
like maybe like a big hollywood movie
yeah yeah when you see like you know
cameos or whatever like that but for
you know stuff where you actually have
to audition for it or whatever like
right um
it
it's completely ridiculous to say that
like oh so-and-so enzo's only getting it
because of this because if so and so is
bad at acting yeah first off everyone's
gonna be able to tell right when it
comes out yeah exactly yeah and there
have been instances where like sometimes
somebody comes out and you're like you
know yeah
but um yeah so there's that the whole
like sometimes people kind of
judge you or go all right you you
shouldn't be in this or whatever um
like i there have definitely been times
where i feel like
i go in to the booth
and they don't know who i am but they
saw i guess they like looked my name up
and this other youtuber like and this
guy really you know can they really do
that
and then i like do it and they're like
oh okay
which is absurd to me because
you know a lot of voice actors come from
like stand-up comedy backgrounds yeah
it's like you have to start somewhere
right like you don't come out of the
[ __ ] womb of voice actor yeah yeah
but for some reason everyone thinks a
youtuber is just like well
okay that's just a bunch of clowns man
yeah i think we're brainless clowns
which yeah some of us are yeah
i get it but you know it it's also kind
of unfair to completely dismiss someone
yeah just because they're they're that
this episode is sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer guys how often do you
shop online all the time all the time
all the time outside it's disgusting
right now i want to stay inside well how
often do you feel like you have a promo
code just ready to go at the checkout
never really well thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes are
a thing of the past honey is a free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it can find to your cards for free joey
what did you save money on using honey i
saved fifteen dollars on that among us
plushie right there a mogus
and it was so easy to use because did
you know it doesn't just work on desktop
it works on your iphone too just
activate it on safari on your phone and
boom you can save on the go boys oh my
god if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings and by getting it you're doing
yourself a solid and lost as well so
what are you waiting for go to honey.com
trash taste that's honey.com
trash taste
back to the episode also
uh
if
a big social media presence was all it
took
to be cast in something yeah i will say
frankly there would have been i would
have booked a lot more other things
that i was like really close to right
there have been projects
like where i was like the runner-up
right i was either the runner-up guy or
in the last three or whatever right yeah
um and in the end
uh they pick whoever they think is the
best fit right yeah it was frankly just
like that guy's got big twitter numbers
we want the twitter numbers it's like
if that was alone the deciding factor
then i would have gotten it right um
which is like kind of a position of like
it's kind of nice and like at least i'm
not being like just you know thought of
as a number but i'm also like i wanted
that part
so but it's like also reassuring of like
oh but you know it's not because of what
some [ __ ] reason that whatever
follows yeah yeah
um but i also feel like for me i don't
get a lot of that
backlash yeah for some reason i don't
know maybe because i've been doing it
for so long or whatever i think it's
like maybe the first time a youtuber
who's also maybe uh like join
starts doing voice acting maybe the
first time that maybe get a little bit
yeah yeah uh i think it's also just
because you're genuinely good
i appreciate it
good then yeah i can see where the
backlash is coming from right i mean i i
appreciate that yeah and uh yeah i i
think it would be clear if you know you
can something yeah you can tell someone
exactly exactly i occasionally got the
comments of like oh it's pretty good for
a youtuber
and everyone was like and then like
again people would probably he literally
has like voice actor in his name since
like 10 years right
yeah it's weird because like sometimes
when you do youtube especially when
you're like more revolving around skits
and comedy stuff you forget that you
know you you are able to do you know
serious voice acting as well your skill
sets just are more broad than just haha
funny guy on the internet
like sometimes hard to
change or change the perception of that
especially to your audience yeah as well
i mean even live action actors deal with
that right like a lot of comedic actors
who try to switch the drum dramatically
like oh i can't take him seriously yeah
yeah it's like
you know people like to put people in
the boxes right yeah exactly you do this
and only do that funny man or do this
and don't even think you know which can
be reductive yeah i mean like yeah
speaking of like live-action acting
you've done that as well with uh you how
was the transition from my voice acting
to doing something like was it anime
crunch division yeah yeah yeah yeah no
um
this is the this is the crunchyroll this
is the control freddy w
yeah rocket jump what was the what was
like the plot of this thing again uh the
plot of anime crimes division is uh we
live in a neo otaku city and we are
detectives who solve anime crimes
it was very fun we did two seasons of it
yeah um
yeah that was like a big
crazy experience for me because i had
had no real live action experience prior
to that and it was definitely like a
crash course but i was fortunate in that
i was with like the most welcoming crowd
of people like i'm friends with freddie
already yeah yeah yeah i i told him like
frankly like he i i wasn't even living
here yet i flew out to do it the first
season and i was like
are you sure i i'm gonna be okay for
this and he's like you'll be fine like
he was like i'm not you'll be great and
it it honestly worked out like
it was super
challenging yeah uh probably like one of
the most like
challenging things i've done like
you know there's so i was the lead in it
and there's so much dialogue so yeah i
have memorized
all that dialogue and uh in the second
season i do a a whole choreographed
fight sequence that's like
it that took like
maybe
five six hours to learn and then to
shoot maybe like
even longer than that right so
it was it was definitely like a crazy
experience but i learned a lot of like
how you do you know live-action film
yeah like hit your mark like i didn't
know what like you know hitting your
mark and
what does that mean hitting your mark is
on a live action set uh if you need to
land on a certain spot for the camera
they put an x on there right with tape
or whatever and they're like okay so
like when you're walking up to this guy
hit this mark and whatever all right
then you're gonna not look at the market
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna do as
naturally as possible or um and then you
gotta remember your lines as well when i
remember your lines and do other things
yeah like uh it's definitely a big
departure from voice acting which
90 of the time you don't have to
memorize anything yeah unless you're
doing like motion capture right
and so that all i mean that was a big
help for me because
later i did god of war ragnarok
where
i had to again memorize lines that i had
written also because they had me write
for it uh and and that was
i was doing it
and i was like
[ __ ] idiot why did you give yourself
so many lines
like i have no one else to blame
why were you writing the lines
uh they asked they specifically wanted
me to do it oh wow
what was the role uh the character is uh
ratatoskr uh right uh i can't say too
much because it's not out yet oh yeah
yeah oh wow when you said god of war
ragnarok i was like that's not out yeah
it's not out yeah but i but i have
announced it like okay okay yeah yeah
okay yeah i'm not i'm not just casually
spilling ndas on yeah yeah yeah
i was just like
people know that i have written for it
acted in it and did the motion capture
awesome and that i uh the name of the
character but i don't think they know
anything else right
are you allowed to talk about what kind
of a process it is to do mocap i can
talk about generally yeah okay yeah
because i've always found that super
interesting how like live action and
then you know you i like you see the
behind the scenes of like you know it's
like the last of us like
the original my god of war
how challenging is it being on a set and
just having like a bunch of [ __ ]
ping pong balls on youtube
uh it's it's definitely yeah the
outfit's really goofy yeah um
for me i had to do these things where
you
uh
they're like filming you and before you
shoot you do like sort of like uh
motions you're doing promotions and like
making sure the the model is like on
like sync with you or whatever yeah um
and that's like a whole thing uh
you have to like sometimes you have to
do like the facial capture as well and
they have like a giant
thing on you yeah um
yeah it was
it was definitely
like very
like intimidating but because i had done
the
anime crimes division i
used to like okay just memorize your
lines and yeah go through the scene uh
and yeah it was
it was very
very fun experience is it hard to like
get in character when the entire like
set on everything is just virtual and
you just no cause voiceover often you're
just in a booth oh that's right like
unless you're dubbing anime or um
like sometimes with cartoons they give
you them
the storyboards right
oftentimes like uh in a video game or
something or most things you're not you
have nothing right but you are just
looking at a script so you have to
imagine yourself in it anyway yeah so
actually having other actors to
interact with
uh was
more helped with the immersion more than
when you're usually just alone in a
booth right i just remembered that you
voiced one of the
playable characters in borderlands 3 yep
i forgot what the name of the character
is
yeah yeah that was awesome yeah that was
like oh [ __ ] dude this is like where
everyone knew that it got announced
mm-hmm it's awesome yeah that was one of
like
the i think that was like the role of
like oh like this is a big yeah well i
think before that they've been like you
know what's in in indie stuff and like
some things but that was like the first
sort of
uh
oh like a lot of people know about this
yeah um
yeah so is there like a particular
franchise or series that is like the
ultimate like i want to voice in this
kind of thing
you haven't done yet do you have one
oh man i'm
joking i feel like if you say it it's a
curse right i know
but obviously i'd love to be in georgia
yeah of course yeah yeah
but who knows when for me i'll say it
because i have the same feeling like i
don't want it it's like a curse if you
say it out loud yeah it's like you're
gonna have to yeah all right
it could be a second no no this is i
mean this is the one that like is very
dear to my heart and it's a ace attorney
oh yeah
i would
lose my mind if i was in
any ace attorney game or
anything like that like because for me
that was one of the things i used to
fandom oh yeah
i was like i'll take because they didn't
have voices so i'll take this character
i'll give them a voice and
uh like i did it so much that like the
fan community definitely associates my
voices for characters yeah
some of the characters yeah so like if i
got a chance to
be a part of that that would definitely
be like
feel like a full circle like oh man yeah
um yeah and like i've i've been
fortunate enough that i've had that
experience with like i mean borderlands
was one where like i played borderlands
2 when i was a kid and i was like
oh one day i maybe i'll be able to do
something like this never thinking one
day that the third one would be i would
be one of the main characters yeah so
i've i've definitely been fortunate
enough to because i'm also a big
fan of this stuff you know i love anime
in video games
actually i often tell people i'm like
sometimes i wish i wasn't such a big fan
because then i wouldn't be so crushed
that i'm like you know not in place
i'm like oh i got to read for this but
oh i'm not in it like like a lot of the
older guards are like i don't know what
this [ __ ] is yeah this is japanimation i
don't know what it is
i don't play video games with pac-man i
don't know i'm like i don't know what
this is i've been playing this since
i've been like 15 years old
you definitely have that like um
you know attachment to it yeah yeah yeah
get crushed when you don't get the role
if you like sunk everything into the
other
uh i think at this point uh you just get
just get used to it yeah i just assume i
don't i'm i'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm doing it right yeah you
should even got it and if you get that
email sick yeah just put do the audition
senate i'm like if
i'll hear back if i get it
yeah i i think the one person who i've
seen get her like dream role recently
and it was weird uh seeing because i've
followed her career like basically since
the beginning with kyrie buckland oh
yeah seeing seeing her like be like the
jojo girl yeah right she wanted to be
yeah yeah yeah and just like because i
remember back she was she always started
on like va and just seeing her career
just like uh
yeah
she recently just voiced jolene in jojo
part six and she [ __ ] killed it i'm
like damn man i'm i'm [ __ ] happy for
her because i've like it's like i'm i've
seen her like progress her career yeah
since since the beginning another
example of again like a lot of people
who are working today are like you know
they've just been grinding and working
at it forever you know yeah yeah yeah so
you said you were a massive board game
fan and i've seen some of your videos
like reviewing board games and
everything as well so the dismay of your
youtube yeah to just see this to the
dismay of like your entire audience it
seems like i will say though on that
like even though i make fun of the fact
that they don't get a lot of views uh
well there was one time i think i did
so
those of you don't know i uh in
tumblr days i did goofy covers right
yeah yeah yeah and then uh uh everyone
that used to be the thing i was like
dude on the goofy do another couple
cover and i was like if i become known
as the goofy cover man
i'm i'm going to walk into the ocean
i cannot let this be my legacy
so i stopped yeah
and then um that was maybe like i don't
know eight maybe like eight years pass
or whatever yeah and then for a charity
milestone i was like okay i will do a
goofy cover and then i was like oh this
is kind of fun again so i started doing
it yeah but then like i posted one and
then someone was like what the hell is
this [ __ ] where are the board game
reviews i'm like
nothing
nothing i can do is will please anybody
like but but i was like wow the board
game reviews have been around for so
long that even then people are like we
want that like they hate change they
hate any kind of like this isn't what
you do you do the skits eating 20 things
and these shitty board game reviews that
don't do well
not this what is this thing i'm like
okay
um
but yeah anyway just can't get a dub man
just yeah yeah
uh
let's say you were asking yeah what are
some board games you recommend because
like i'm not so much into the board game
scene and so like i see someone like you
and i you know occasionally watch some
of your reviews and some of your videos
what like what to you makes a good board
game what do you what have you played if
anything [ __ ] the
monopoly i've made them play uh ticket
to ride oh yeah we'll play tickets
that's that's fun i really like risk as
well yeah okay yeah
um
if you
um let's see
like uh do you like cooperative games do
you like uh
more competitive games like what are you
what are you what's your style
i'd say
let's say cooperative cooperative yeah
yeah yeah like pandemic is like a good
one to start uh that one's you're
running around the world trying to like
you know cure disease yeah uh and
nowadays
yeah uh and feel sad about how the real
one's going away
like that's that one's good um
maybe we should have played that before
like
long campaign right now right
my favorite board game is marvel
legendary which is a cooperative uh deck
building game uh deck building being
like not like magic
uh you have a market of cards you're
feeling like slate aspire or something
any of you i've never played this okay
anyway yeah wait i i know obviously this
fire i know how it works deck building
as a concept is like you have these
random cards you add you slowly start
adding them to your basic deck and then
like get rid of all your shitty cards
and go your deck becomes stronger as you
go right right inscription yes
inscription is a deck building game yeah
the description was really really good
yeah it was an amazing game um so like a
lot of the deck building ones are really
good
i mean i don't know it really just
depends on
what you
what you've got so many games and yeah
yeah
yeah
the sheer amount of reviews you've done
yeah it's just like oh my god yeah i saw
like the table that you got given
i'm
yeah
it's like i would like to get that table
just to play board games you know i'll
get that table first and i'm just like
okay now i need to get now i need some
board games to play is it bad that i
think i remember the name is it the
woodworm table or something the uh the
wormwood
is the company okay all right right
right it's this table the just like
there's a like a it's a normal table and
then it just all comes off with magnets
there's cup holders that can slide
around yeah it's just a playing area
with like a felt it looks amazing yeah
it's beautiful
like i was using my kitchen table for
the longest time with like a with a mat
right um and that was fine but then like
this thing i'm like oh it's so
it's so good like because the table
topper uh before this uh whenever we
ordered food or whatever and the games
on the table it's like all right
everyone go stand awkwardly in the
kitchen and like eat off like counters
or whatever yeah yeah but now it's like
okay break put the toppers on we can eat
on top
it's so good cup holders it's just
beautiful it's awesome dude this thing
is awesome yeah yeah i want that's like
the premium board game experience that i
won
how did you get like how did that hobby
start was that something you were always
like into and then you just kind of like
grew from there it started from um uh i
was at an otakon back in like i want to
say like 2012 or something like right it
might even be maybe around then it's out
of conan that's in uh it used to be in
baltimore now in dc okay uh and uh just
a group of friends and i we were at
there was there's a barnes and noble in
the inner harbor where that khan used to
be and uh none of us had really played a
lot of designer board games or whatever
we saw a game called forbidden island uh
which is a great game actually right and
the cover was cool that a silly name
were like oh what is this like let's
just buy it like if it's stupid it will
just you know it's fun let's just try it
yeah and if it's great and we were
really into it it's a cooperative game
where like you're trying to collect
these artifacts and the island is
sinking and you have to get off like in
time or whatever yeah
simple design but very fun and we were
like oh [ __ ] this is great like are
there other games like this and so it
became like a rabbit hole we would it's
yeah like i i i often introduce a lot of
people to
the hobby right like oh have you tried
this and then they're like oh [ __ ] like
war games can be like this because a lot
of people are associated with like
monopoly
yeah yeah yeah um or even like you know
for me
katan i find kind of dull like i had
played katan prior and i was like this
is fine i don't really give a [ __ ] but
forbidden island i was like oh okay
these can be like and now i play like
everything yeah um
because then you discover like there's a
website called board game geek that like
you know ranks all the games and you're
and it becomes and then people started
gifting me
games yeah yeah yeah um so it really
just snowballed right some of the
complexity of those board games is just
insane yeah the learning curve right
there's something like multi-day things
right like they could be well
i think multi-day might be an
exaggeration but there's definitely ones
that i've played that have taken like
maybe like 12 hours
like that's like
all right comment like in the morning
and you we will be done at like 11 p.m
like
that's a commitment man yeah yeah that's
and for me actually the the sweet spot
is like
middle complexity yeah light to middle
yeah because i like complex games but
they're harder to get to the table
because only like
die hards are going to want to like play
those it's hard to teach it to people
it's hard to teach people it's
intimidating and oftentimes very hard to
you know just get into yeah so they're
sort of like on board game they sort it
from like one to five scale right like
the two to three scale is usually like
perfect because it's like one or two is
like party games which are fun but two
to three is like
there's some meat on these bones but
it's not like it's not that hard to
grasp yeah once you get to three to four
that's a little beefier four and up is
like that is complex like it is like a
good like gate like you want to get
someone into board games you have like a
good gateway game you like that you
always bring out to be like hey monopoly
here's his little thing to like wait
your appetite just to see like what this
hobby
not only be on that difficulty skills
what is it a one
i think it's probably i could even
search right now my guess is like one or
something right
like maybe with the trading it slightly
but it's you're literally just rolling
dyson yeah yeah yeah exactly
um let's see a good
gateway
game like what's the attack on titan of
board games you know
i mean
ticket to right yeah i feel like ticket
to ride is a really good interest that's
a good one just because it's so simple
and like yeah you're just making sets
and like making uh i don't i don't care
if this is not protocol and here i'm
probably gonna you can do it yeah you
can you can do it because i like to get
to riots i find that there is a way
for me it's like if you can have the
opportunity to strategize
and really like implement it while still
having that that luck factor yeah yeah
where a noob could just completely get
lucky and beat you like i like that
that's what i really like about risk
yeah it's exactly the same thing where
it's like it looks
really intimidating because it's such a
big game but when you actually get into
and you learn the rules it's very you
can very quickly start strategizing
right now so some good ones like azul is
a very uh elegant like sort of abstract
game with like really nice tiles
and that one has like like there's
different ones in the series that's
there's like a zuolo and azul stained
glass of cintra and it's just like it
has the feel of like a game that's been
around for like you know decades but
it's it's a new what did you do in that
game um it's hard to explain without
visuals but you're basically you have
these circles of tiles and you're
drafting colors of tiles and you're sort
of filling up rows okay you're trying to
get them in like an array make combos
right which is completely impossible to
explain without me actually having the
pieces yeah
but it has the feeling you do your best
so there's there's that one um
like a really popular one it's like code
names have you ever played that one do
you know that one
code names is like you have a grid of
words uh and one person or your each
team has a code map code name or code
master or whatever right and they give a
clue like uh
furry three and their your team is
trying to like pick what are the which
of these were three words fit that clue
but the thing is if you touch a clue of
the other team's words they get the
point right and there's a kill word
where if anyone touches that they
instantly lose oh so it's like it's like
an array of like i think like 25 words
half of them are red on the back half of
them are blue yeah not on the back
there's like a little card and then they
have them are blanks which are like duds
and then there's a kill card right so
it's like a really like elegant just
like
hey this is this i i basically just
explained how to play it now yeah yeah
yeah
and a number and that's how many fit
that thing and just and you're like okay
it's a good party game it's a really
good party game yeah
uh
i'm gonna write these down yeah yeah
yeah yeah
luckily it's being filmed right now
right yeah uh dixit you know what dixon
oh i love dixit it's just very very it's
a really fun game that is one where
you're playing um these surreal picture
cards uh and you're trying to give a
clue as to uh
like it's like reverse pictionary almost
the idea is that you wanna um
get uh give a clue
so that not everyone uh picks the card
uh because if everyone picks the card
then
you get [ __ ] but if nobody picks your
card you get [ __ ] so you're trying to
give a clue that's just
obscure enough where it's like because
what happens is you put down the card
and everyone else puts down a card that
matches that clue right right everyone's
trying to and you're trying to you're
trying to figure out which one was the
original card right so if i said like uh
uh mysterious or whatever and i put down
a card and everyone else puts on a card
then we reveal them and everyone's like
which one was the original mysterious
card right one that's fun in that game
as a clue is super mario brothers three
because then everything because then
there's so many surprisingly like
fitting cards for right
or like something like that or you say a
video gamer or like dreamworks movies or
something and then like people are
revealing they all look like [ __ ]
dreamworks movies yeah although all the
cars look like salvador dali paintings
they're like really abstract they're all
really strange like surreal okay
yeah that one's really fun that one's
really good um from an island i
mentioned it's a really fun co-op yeah
um yeah those are like just some some
very like basic level ones that sounds
really fun yeah thank you for watching
yeah thank you for the recommendations
future trash taste after talking yeah
hell yeah i'm down you're just giving us
content ideas now that's perfect yeah
so moving on from that i guess i saw you
uh got got some flack on like tick tock
the other day for like calling what was
it
like
a niche anime yeah i'm sure which
do you disagree i don't disagree i was
asked
like wait wait sorry sorry i i i
sorry i agree that it is a niche anime
so i was wondering why you were getting
flack for it that
ah i'd say it's on borderline like i
know i know what it is but i mean like i
don't know well because like karuta is
like a
subculture where if you're really not
into i'd say japanese subculture then
it's hard to grow i'd say it's new yeah
it's pretty so i the reason well it was
just a very simple video where they're
like how do you prove that you're the
real pros of the and i was like well i
have a custom made figure from the niche
anime chat through which i specifically
when i was making it was like at first i
was gonna say
i was like should i say obscure i was
like no if i say obscure
people are gonna be like
and i was like okay i'll say niche
because niche is different than obscure
yeah niche just means like oh it's more
geared towards like a specific subset
yeah
niche can have a little more of a
positive obscure means not well known
like yeah
you know like not well-known yeah niche
is like oh it's more like this audience
than it's mean yeah yeah it's it's
definitely nice
whether it's obscure i mean i even i
might like i might even call it obscure
nowadays because you look at like how
popular anime is nowadays and like 90
percent of anime fans i think do you not
know children it's obscure for western
audiences oh yeah yeah you know in japan
it does really well yeah yeah yeah but
like yeah you ask your average
anime fan okay which is again what
you're which i'm which i'm uh which
you're basically judging it right yeah
exactly if i ask like anime twitter yeah
you know what chihayofuru is yes you've
heard of it right but if i ask a like
you know i uh
in a
future later tick tock i was like yeah
i've been to i've been a guest at cons
and i'll do a q a it's like hundreds of
people i'll be like anyone here watch
chai furu
one guy yeah exactly right exactly
anyone know what it is like five people
you know yeah um i mean i think i think
a lot of people who are like especially
like anime fans or like have been anime
fans for a very very long time they
forget
how like
how un like how widespread it's become
now and how
some popular animes back in the day are
just like not well known now at all like
it's it's it's weird to think that even
like you know something like guru nagan
is how many years old now and about like
15 years it's like it's like 15 years
old and that's that's that's like i
would even say to like the mo to like
the modern anime fan like
that seems like a niche anime now i i
like a lot of new animals i remember you
just reminded me there was this moment
where i was like going on about like a
bunch of shows on on my twitch yeah and
then i started a poll oh we were talking
about haruhi
and i started a poll saying because i
saw a couple of people being like i've
never heard of it and so i was like so i
was like okay okay
mods start a poll
who has seen harry yeah and it was a it
was legit 50 50. wow
and i'm like and it just like put into
perspective like oh yeah like there's
been a lot of shows since haruhi yeah
yeah even though like for you know our
generation haruki was like inescapable
but it was like it was like the it was
his show
you're gonna you're gonna be like yeah
of course i stopped watching during the
[ __ ] endless eight oh of course of
course
it was so boring that's the point
why the [ __ ] would i want to watch it if
it's boring it's art
i will say yo disappearance makes it
worth it yeah this makes the
disappearance of haruhi
is a [ __ ] amazing
i i told these boys the story before but
i actually watched the disappearance
before i watched anything else
i was very confused and bored
and you know you want to know how it
happened
how
this was back when i just became an
anime fan right so naturally where am i
going to go to find recommendations for
shows yeah my anime list yeah yeah that
was one of the highest
of the highest like top five rated
things the disappearance of harry
suzumiya yeah i didn't know about any
other show so i just watched it and i
was like damn this sucks ass why is
everyone saying this is good
i'm gonna kill you
i'm gonna absolutely kill you so this is
i watched it when i was like you know
17. did you also watch haruhi in
chronological orders [ __ ]
i watched it
broadcast order i i watched it in the
actual order of the episodes
yeah the broadcast broadcast yeah yeah
yeah
you saved yourself there yeah at least
so but this was like years after i
watched this appearance yeah did you
watch disappearance again afterwards i
have not i should probably do that yeah
yeah
you need to finish endless eight first
yeah yeah you gotta i mean i will say
the best thing about it was probably uh
just like watching it like dab crispin
freeman was really good
yeah yeah even though he had no idea
what was going on yeah he was so good i
mean he's getting everything there yeah
yeah yeah i mean he's he's just one of
those voice actors where you just it's
just like a pleasure it's like
just to hear him act but yeah i mean uh
that was okay
i i even the first season i was like
yeah
it's fine yeah did you watch avengers
end the game without watching anything
else
that's actually a good conference that's
actually a good comparison i i watch
some of the other things you know
[Music]
so what was the backlash significant
because you know
it wasn't it wasn't significant it was
like anime fan backlash i was just like
also teasing but like you know it was
definitely
i'm sure you guys also do this too like
when i make a tweet sometimes i'm like
writing something i'm like okay i'm like
thinking of like how people will be like
well actually well actually okay so
change this word to this yeah yeah
like like i have to like explain the
joke or whatever or making like clear i
don't mean this not this like to be
honest it's just not worth it because
like top 10 easiest things to do in the
world number one is breathe and number
two is piss off anime fans sure it's
just like not worth it i i feel like
there are like different levels right
because if you were talking about most
of them off like 10 seconds
you talk about most anime i feel like
there's some leeway but if you have an
opinion on any shonen anime then you are
literally like going to a battlefield
you know you are literally stepping on
my minefields at that point and yeah i
feel like any you say anything and
you'll get like some kind of backlash
sure it's also just really funny though
it is it is it is it is but you don't
watch many recent shows right you're
more you love the classics it's not that
i avoid recent shows but it's more like
i have less time to watch stuff now so
for me it's more i want to pick and
choose right i pick and choose so and
uh
oh man i mean i'm at the perfect spot i
i do want to talk some anime so like
uh
yeah i don't i haven't seen like demon
slayer or jiu jitsu hyson yeah yeah and
it's not like i'm not going to watch
these things yeah it's more like
uh i don't know i'm watching uh maria
watches over us do you know that one
no
that is uh that is the uh yuri catholic
uh
high school girl anime
it's very good no no it's like
over yeah that sounds funny
[Music]
or something might be the what the fans
call it or something it is a four season
show about uh
high school catholic girls and
oh this this is in 2004 holy [ __ ]
yeah i just watched the fourth season of
that uh like this this is obscure that's
that's that's this is
like when i when when i first met you
speaking about oh you like anime i was
like yeah i like anime he started naming
shows and i was like oh [ __ ]
i was like i don't i don't i'm not like
this kind of animation yeah yeah i i
know i'm not a loser
i'm like a medium level of
knowledge yeah it's like you're getting
deep
no i don't even think i've seen that no
this is like before i started watching
things seasonally so
how did you find this anime so it's
funny you mentioned my anime list
i don't use my anime list i since i
since i first started my weeb journey
i've used anime news network's top anime
oh okay i didn't even realize they had a
topic nobody does everyone uses my anime
list yeah yeah but anime news network if
you go to their um top there's a top
hundred and you can see oh boy it's i'm
such a loser you can sort it by buying
us at like estimate and like rank and it
ranks at the top 500. right right and
like it does up like
that's high function
right uh i go to that list for like
what's on here
if something pierces the top hundred
right i know it's worth watching so like
odd taxi pierced it right yeah or uh and
i watched that and yeah ranking of kings
pierced it yeah so i watched amazing
like
when i watch new stuff i'm like okay if
it hit the top hundred and on that
website yeah then i'm like something
special real [ __ ] yeah cause cause like
i feel like with a lot of the new [ __ ]
that's popular right now like things
like demon slayer and jiu-jitsu guys and
they're good you know they're good and
they do well on that on that site like
because they're they're good i mean i
haven't seen them but i from what i
understand they're like good quality
yeah but like for like i feel like if
you've watched any shonen before it's
it's kind of the same thing it's the
same formula it's just good again yeah
like
[ __ ] shows shonen jump have just got
this thing on lockdown yeah they've got
the formula they've just got the formula
down because anything anytime they
release the show it's always good you
cut like you know you kind of know what
to expect there are there are like
differences in every show but you you
get the same feeling every time you know
and and so like you you don't need to be
you don't need to be in a rush to watch
like jiu-jitsu guys in except if you
just want to talk to people about it
nowadays you just want to be in the inn
yeah but like with a lot of like more
obscure shows you know
isn't that the hot button i guess so i
guess i guess it is
let's do it this show is very obscure
that is an obscure show my only problem
with my anime list is top 100 because i
have looked at it is that i feel like
new shows get favored really quickly yes
yeah like to be on anime news networks
like to get up there
it has to be like really good yeah where
sometimes i'll see stuff on there and
i'm like i'm sure it's good but i think
this is just on you because it's new
yeah
uh like and uh
my anime list also has this like weird
like
it also gets weirdly political as well
because it's like there's this like i've
noticed this is hardcore dedicated group
of people on my anime list who are like
if full metal alchemist brotherhood is
not number one we riot wow yeah and it's
like it's just this dedicated group that
just does everything that they can to
try and keep certain shows in certain
places yeah no matter what see not
enough people care about anime news
network's ratings
so it's actually like pretty accurate
yeah because i remember that happened
when your name came out yeah and it was
like it was getting really close to
being number one yeah and then there was
this whole like coup d'etat happening of
like no we must keep full metal
alchemist brotherhood at number one yeah
and then they succeeded yeah meanwhile
like the gintama fans would be like we
want every season of kintama in the top
10.
here's the thing though like i haven't
i've only seen a little bit of gintama i
do intend to watch all of it at some
point yeah but it's amazing but getting
tom all those seasons and movies those
pierce anime news network so i'm like
yeah yeah this has got to be they're all
great yeah yeah yeah yeah i do need to
watch that yeah so this tells a lot
about the type of person i am uh my goal
at one point is to have watched
everything in the top hundred on anime
news network okay oh okay so that's why
i watched maria watches over season four
that's why i finished have you seen i
mean i'm sure you have clinette click
clan ad after story of course yeah i
hadn't i i didn't i watched clint
clinton is it clinic
what clan ad clan ad yeah i watched it
like when it came out and i hadn't i
never finished it right so like season
right yeah yeah because it wasn't that
good and then the the like like like two
weeks ago i was like all right i'm gonna
finally watch it
and
yeah it was i was surprised it was
surprisingly good that the after story
is very sad yeah yeah very sad that last
quarter without spoiling anything i was
like this is great i think it's fair
game to spoil it after i haven't seen
off the story what the [ __ ] yeah it
turns into a different show yeah yeah
and it's great it's the build-up of the
first season that makes the second
season it was the first season that
killed it for me right now me too yeah
it is with a lot of people
you know i saw how highly rated after
story was and i thought i'll i'll watch
it for after story yeah
i would never normally watch planet
nowadays yeah i'm too yeah
season two yeah climate season one is is
pretty tough to watch nowadays yeah yeah
the characters are like the worst
archetypes of every kind of anime
ever except
kyo
yes i love cure yeah it was the better
okay
man of taste
okay yeah no i agree with you with uh my
anime this thing though with like it's
there's a lot of recency bias on there
where if there's like a new popular show
or expired family getting like yeah yeah
oh my god it's a 10 out of 10. there's
only three episodes out but yeah
but like why is quick sometimes i look
at the top 100 on mount and i'm just
like
am i the old one
is is it is the show that good or or am
i just like the the titans
don't tell me you've only seen the 2003
anime i haven't watched any because
anyway okay because because like the
reason is that like i remember like when
i started getting into anime you know
you you you watch banger off the banger
off the bang you're like anime is
[ __ ] awesome and then you watch a bit
more you're like [ __ ]
am i going to run out of good anime
so like saving it for a rainy day yeah
yeah yeah so so i it mentally i was just
like i'm going to save full metal
alchemist because i know i'm going to
like it i'm going to save it for a race
boss yeah yeah yeah and then and then
like it's just been years later and i
just i i know what you mean though
because i'm like that with hunter hunter
uh because
because it's like i i know so much about
the show just through osmosis that like
when i talk about certain parts of the
show people just think that i've seen
the show but i haven't actually sat down
and read it or watched it okay yeah okay
i get what you mean yeah so like it's
like an example i'm looking at the list
now and like the new season of demon
slayer is the 23rd best anime of all
time i'm just like did the new demon
slayer slap yes yes is this the 23rd of
all time is it the 23rd of all time
because people watch the last three
episodes the animation was insane and
they were typed as [ __ ] like to compare
again this is going to be not
interesting well actually will this be
interesting to you i think it is this
would be interesting you still have
weebs listening to this yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean we stand up we we like to
pretend every now and again that's uh
three you said you said that was 23rd
yeah so to compare
on um anime news network uh
they are that is at let me pull it up so
to compare on anime news network that's
at like 209
but that's really good out of the
thousands of shows that have you know
yeah yeah i i [ __ ] love these green
bars it makes my i don't know why it
makes my [ __ ] brain go yeah you know
it's great right yeah i always had these
like really pleasing data bars yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so they do like
arithmetic mean weighted mean beating
estimate yeah
all right i've got to look at this list
because i was like going down again yeah
like uh you go to my anime news network
right
news network right now go to uh
oh no go to what is it
uh god so interesting uh
like i'm looking down i'm like 86 part 2
is the 46th best anime of all time no
no no
no
i like 86 as well i like 86 but
uh no i'm in it but i haven't seen it
that's a flex
i don't i don't need to see it i don't
know
it's all army stuff right i don't know
yeah yeah my guy was always like gotta
go on i'm not a remember some kind of
military operations i don't know um so
go to encyclopedia click top ten all
right and then you can click the top 50
and you can go to like
top hundred and then there's 100 top 100
feet 250 top 500 so right now
brotherhood is number one on there but i
think that's just it's quality
that's just that's just like crazy i do
think brotherhood i mean it's great it
is great it's a great package it's got
everything [ __ ] is better but it's
great yeah it's got everything yeah
it does everything amazingly in this
yeah it's a great show and it's you know
it's it chose it was like we're gonna be
64 episodes we're gonna do it perfectly
yeah so let's compare
someone pull up my anime list top ten
you got it oh okay i had it yeah yeah so
and i'll i'll compare the top ten on
anime news network sorry both are so
both number ones are formal articles
number two on here is steins gate oh
that's interesting it was like it wasn't
that my anime was for a while uh number
two on here is gintama
one of those let's go
okay number three steins gate actually
number three on here is clenad after
story oh okay clown number four is your
name
okay yeah um number four on this one is
attack on titan season three part two
okay number five on yours roney kenshin
trust and betrayal that's the samurai x
08 yeah yeah i'm just going to say it
number five number eight number nine are
all guinta jesus okay
sorry what are you doing for him yeah
boy number six on here is code geass
season two which sucked ass but that's
fine
yeah at the end the ending the ending
that whole show sucks
i still don't think oh oh my god
i think
yes has like the best ending in all of
anime i can't think of a better ad
i can't think of a better ending
that's pretty good
damn good ending that's true that's true
i think i think what you said could be
true if that's the only anime you've
ever seen
i can't believe i'm getting called out
uh seven is spirited away then cowboy
bebop number nine is bushish season two
yeah yeah which is very good which is
very good mushy she's like see like from
this one it's like number seven is like
the new car gear summer which i don't
think has even ended it's not finished
yet yeah that's my problem with this
list yeah yeah yeah you gotta wait till
the show's done yeah right the show
could turn to a big big turd like you
know
you've also gotta give it some time
after it's finished too so that like
people can like process processor yeah
yeah i read the miami list reviews when
there's only like two episodes out
they're like i'm gonna review the whole
show now i'm just gonna yeah yeah
i love i love the miami list reviews of
people who drop the show
yeah and they're just like i watched the
two and a half episodes of this and i
thought it was absolutely fantastic 10
out of 10. it's like all right
what do you think you need to like watch
an entire show to review it because who
is it i went through this uh
some critters went through i know what
you're talking about yeah some critics
your movie starts yeah yeah your movie
starts right you uh watch all the movies
to the end because you get but i think
if you drop a show like i feel like if
you're being if you're giving it praise
i feel like you can't give it praise and
only have watched half yeah yeah that's
like that doesn't make any sense if you
if you drop a show it's got to be an a
normally a negative review where do you
all stand on that like is like the whole
can you review a movie or a show without
having watched if the movie is so bad or
boring or uninspired and you're halfway
through it i think it's totally valid to
be like listen i've got a bunch of other
movies to watch yeah this clearly isn't
gonna you know it's already been so bad
in the first 50 minutes yeah how is it
going to turn it all around but here's
the question in a reviewing capacity
though as a viewer i think of course
yeah you don't have to watch everything
yeah yeah yeah but if you're gonna
definitively be like this movie is
bad or this movie is good but you don't
watch the whole thing do you think
that's valid if your job is a movie
review i think it's valid you're
watching so many movies yeah i mean i
mean it depends on like i think it
depends on like a case-by-case basis but
like at the end of the day if a piece of
media is so
bad that a reviewer cannot finish it you
know that
even if it gets better
then statement then
so powerful combination
uh if if if like if an anime is bad up
to a certain point then you like you got
to you got to like
you got to admit that there is something
about this show that
a lot of people would not be able to get
through because it is bad but
in a reviewing capacity
see i completely
disagree i think not with you but yeah
with you i think you disagree with me
yeah no that's fine we already did
i think if you're going to definitively
review something you have to watch the
whole thing i think that's the that's
the minimum you have to do especially
when it's a tv series as well i feel
like yeah because it can very quickly
change and turn and it's a moment we
brought up
right and that like
you know i cannot i could not
authoritatively authoritatively be like
clinette is bad all the way through or
it's just bad because when i finally sat
down and watched and like the last 11
episodes right are quite good but i
can't counterpoint then because i go
okay sure
do you think you need to watch all of
one piece in order to be able to review
it
right like there's some shows where the
length is so absurd yeah like it would
be completely unrealistic to expect like
a reviewer who's their job to get
through all of this media yeah so
imagine how much you would [ __ ] hate
your job if you you're like i have to
review one and that's why i stopped
reviewing anime well i think with one
piece you're not gonna
no no one is gonna be like i'm gonna
review
all of it as a whole yeah if you're
reviewing one piece you're going like
episode by episode or at least arc by
arc yeah because like i feel like you
need to watch enough of something to at
least get like a like a taste or a
feeling about what this show is about
and what it can achieve because like to
me if i hear someone like judge one
piece i like i ask okay how far have you
gotten right like if someone drops it in
like the first few arcs i'm just like
well you didn't even scratch the surface
into what one piece can do if they watch
until alabaster they still don't like it
i'm like okay i understand maybe one
piece just isn't for you at that point i
think it's all about like what
percentage of the overall show you
actually consume right because it's like
you know if you yeah as you said with
the one piece thing if you only watched
like up until the alabaster arc you know
in retrospect that's a very small
percentage of the show that's only a
bite size so
we still have to be specific though on
reviewing capacity yeah yeah yeah just
casual viewing of course no one has to
watch all of one piece to be like it's
not for me yeah yeah yeah yeah if you're
just watching like i'm not really into
it like yeah that's fair yeah yeah and i
often tell people i say kinda like what
you said if you watch arlong park
and after that still don't give a [ __ ]
yeah then i don't think it's gonna work
for you yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
um for me it's like okay let's say
like you said there's a casual view it
doesn't matter if you drop it right yeah
but for me as well it's like if the
reviewer also feels the same way where
he's like i'm cutting out here i'm like
okay that's something i can kind of
relate to because i wouldn't i wouldn't
sit through it and just dredge through
it just because yeah i feel like i have
to finish it it's gonna depend on the
context of what the reviewer is doing
right if the reviewer is like if there's
someone just asking what do you think
about one piece it's like oh i watched
up to this point it wasn't for me yeah
that's fine but if you're putting out
like a video like
is one piece
good or bad or whatever like such a
loaded question as well
and also you know bringing in like a
long show like one piece yeah then
you're gonna have some exceptions yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that would be something you would expect
to be reviewed in chunks yeah right but
if it's a 12 episode show then i think
or even like a two core like watch the
whole thing yeah yeah yeah and a movie
in sp in particular it's like
yeah i i do agree like
with a movie with with a movie you
should
finish it before you review it i mean
you can you can stop you know as a
viewer but if you're reviewing it if
it's a movie yeah i i do think you
should i don't know i i i can only
imagine the life of a movie reviewer as
hell because you you have to watch
most films are
mediocre right yeah
like think about all the movies that
came out last year and and how many of
them remember that's true of like every
piece of media right truth wasn't like
i
i would not expect any insane human to
sit through all of these movies and then
be like yeah this is this is this was
really really bad but i just finished it
because to me it's like if the first
half was super [ __ ] but it got amazing
in the second half it would still lose
marks or points in your head for having
the really [ __ ] first half yeah i i i
dropped 86 everyone got really annoyed
that i didn't like 86. i just thought it
was so boring and i watched nine
episodes nine episodes of the show yeah
that is so much time well you're not
reviewing it you're just viewing it no i
know yeah but i mean i i i could say but
he gave his opinion on trash taste
therefore he's a reviewer
i said i said it was just boring and i
didn't enjoy it and i was nine episodes
i mean listen i watched one episode of
no game no life thought it was dog [ __ ]
and stop watching so you know i'm with
you like
i do intend to sit down and watch it at
some point and actually watch it but as
a casual viewer i was like i don't like
this at all but like i think um it's a
good show yeah yeah
even if with them
the movie was [ __ ] boring but the the
tv series was pretty good okay yeah i
think also some shows are just not for
me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
but yeah i think with the movie i mean i
don't know i do board game reviews right
yeah i played a lot of [ __ ] games yeah
and those take even longer than movies
some games some games take like six
hours to play and you didn't you're done
you're like that was
throughout
horrible
i guess for me if it's like if i'm gonna
review something yeah you wanna i have
to be like because you know there can be
aspects near the end sometimes you watch
a movie and you're like the last 30
minutes yeah it got really interesting
yeah yeah yeah and vice versa i guess
that's why you with reviewers it's kind
of like you know you've got to find the
reviewer that you kind of have the
similar
yeah look on movies or media yeah and
for me i'm like i like it with my
reviewers like this movie was so [ __ ] i
had to drop it 50 minutes in even though
it's my job to finish this it's that bad
that i didn't yeah well yeah when it's
that bad but like i think there's a lot
of like anime especially where it's like
yeah the first half or you know the
first couple of episodes is like really
[ __ ] a weak start right or and but
you know it could have an ending that's
like surprisingly good and i i feel with
anime there's a lot more where it's vice
versa where the start is really really
strong
and then the ending is just dog [ __ ]
like dead man wonderland's like a great
example where it's like first couple of
episodes of [ __ ] like oh my god this
is insane and then it was just dog [ __ ]
near the end right but like you wouldn't
have known that yeah in the manga as
well right but like you wouldn't have
known that if you didn't stick through
it to the end yeah i mean that's like
most seasonal anime nowadays yeah you
watched the first three episodes and
like damn this [ __ ] slash they put
all the effort into the first three yeah
yeah exactly right it's just because of
the way that they make manga right like
you have to have the good initial sales
they got to hook you in yeah yeah yeah
the first few chapters and then they're
like oh [ __ ] we didn't plan this far
ahead yeah yeah yeah but like clan ed
right i would never be like i would
never
judge someone to be like that's [ __ ]
up they were like clan i was so boring i
couldn't make it after story no i
totally that i think that is very fair
it's unreasonable be like you have to
watch 25 episodes before it gets good
what stay with stein's
you know it's like oh the first 11
episodes are boring as [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah i kind of agree with that but like
you know the second half is [ __ ]
incredible yeah i think bottom line it's
like
it just really depends on you know for
casual viewers doesn't matter yeah
reviewers it's gonna your mileage is
gonna vary i think so isn't it weird now
that saying like you have just like
suffer through 25 episodes and that just
feels so long but like back in the day i
remember i would gladly watch like two
seasons of a show like in order before
it gets good you know that was just like
okay easy easy 50 episodes of one piece
until arlong park that's that's yeah i
can get these in the [ __ ] day
episodes until our long pop yeah yeah
okay yeah the the animation is very
dramatic
of one piece is uh is is awful which is
why you're saying the dbz right and like
all those shows back then yeah yeah yeah
yeah funny going back to a topic we kind
of
touched on let's talk about obscure
anime
sure great what do you want to talk
about are some obscure anime titles that
you
really like
how are obscure i know joe's going to
the same thing it's time to fight right
i know joey's going to say mononoke
right now
i need to see that i think that's i
think it's one of the best
yeah
i would say it's really obscure i've
never heard of it yeah right yeah
mononoke is i think one of the best
horror anime to be ever made yeah hands
down like it's it's like genuinely the
only show that actually creeped me out
yeah and that's very difficult to do
because there's a lot of really [ __ ]
mediocre horror anime out there sure
sure you know
would you say like legends of the
galactic heroes is obscure because i
don't i don't know nowadays it would be
because yeah i've i've known like a lot
of people prior to the reboot maybe yeah
yeah because i know a lot of people
who've heard of legends of black heroes
but i hardly know anyone who's actually
watched it
you know all right it's one of those
shows where people put it on like
they're to watch this as like one of the
shows they have to watch and then no one
ever watches it like a brotherhood yeah
yeah
it's on the same level
that's that's a pretty obscure show
right this one for me have you any of
you seen garage mr stain on junk alley i
have not was could you say when did that
come out
and junk alley i think in like 2005 or
something
jerry normally sometimes knows the
japanese yeah
whatever the job i think it might be
okay
google it
i'm trying to figure out what your
baseline for would you say boccarano is
obscure
uh
i haven't seen book around i know what
it is yeah it's one of my favorite shows
is that the one we were talking about
with the
kids
yeah yeah yeah this is one of my
all-time favorites i would say cause
yeah um did you google it it looks
bizarre it's like a cg
series of shorts is this that
let me see
mystery and junk alley
yeah
i've never seen that what is this check
it out sometime it's hilarious this
looks like a video game
you gotta you gotta you gotta show this
yeah
it looks like a pc game from like the
90s oh i see like the old the og
funimation logo on this yeah
no funimation put it out they didn't dub
it but uh what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah how did you find this anime a
friend of mine was just like hey let's
watch this i was like what the [ __ ] is
this and it was
great like at first i thought it was
just gonna be like
stupid yeah and it kind of is but it's
so
so weird and so entertaining like i
thoroughly
thoroughly enjoyed it right like it's
just the weirdest funniest like
that's it's surreal so the problem with
a lot of obscure anime is that a lot of
them are not that great it's probably
it's probably the reason why they're
obscure as well like because like it's
it's really hard to find like a real
diamond in the rough when it comes to
anime because now nowadays especially
people know about so many people are
exploring different ones watches
everything yeah that like now whenever
an obscure show does kind of pop out
from under the ground then people are
going to start talking about it i really
want to watch more of those you know
when you see clips of like they they
people just post like 30 minutes like
amazing animations from those like 80
yeah yeah yeah you wanna watch more of
those yeah it's like yeah because there
seems to be so many cool ovas dudes
there are so many like 80s and 90s ovas
where it's just like
i didn't think 120 frames per second
anime existed until i saw the 90s i
really want to watch some of those but
i'm just like where the [ __ ] do i even
begin but even those even those like
obscure 90s ova's like back then and
like the early 2000s they were like
like you know like if you talk about
like jenna cyber or something right or
like violence jack where it's like no
one [ __ ] watched those back in the
day but now they're like so [ __ ]
obscure that people are talking about it
again and now they're like more talked
about them before so it's like because
you know i mean i wouldn't say genocide
is a good show necessarily it's violent
as [ __ ] that's probably the reason why
it's been talked about but like yeah a
lot of a lot of problems with the
obscure shows is that like most of them
in my opinion are like a five out of ten
and that's why no one wants to talk
about it but also it's just like it's
really interesting just to watch that
like kind of like ova period where it
just seemed it it felt underground you
know like where it just felt like anime
went through this like edgy teen phase
where just like let's make everything as
violent as [ __ ] possible yeah i
watched it i i went on like i remember
going on like a binge of like these like
90s and 80s ovas when i was in my i'm 14
and this is deep era and it was the best
but even though even though a lot of the
shows were so [ __ ] just like on the
grander scale of things it's just like
yay blood violence sex woo
yeah
well like
i was i was gonna say like stuff like
even like the original devil man was
like obscure until he got the the remake
oh no one had heard of devil man
basically before he got remade
huh well i mean it's also extremely old
it was like made in the 60s or 70s i
think yeah yeah yeah i was gonna ask do
any of you are any of you like me and
like vlog every anime you've ever
watched
i i did for a while like my anime list
yeah yeah i did for a while until it
just i don't know i i stopped doing it
it was an achievement after a while i
got like
yeah
yeah kind of like kind of like gamified
watching anime for me and then i didn't
really like that because sometimes i
love gamifying everything in my life i
love it the board game guys
was like i gamepl enjoy this
like why am i finishing this yeah i
literally am watching like wasting hours
of my life to finish the show just so i
could put it on my [ __ ] just so i can
talk about it for like two minutes of
the video yeah right yeah it wasn't
they were just like like ruining my
enjoyment to a lot of shows so i stopped
doing it and i'm sorry to hear that but
that's the exact opposite with me oh
really right that's why i watched
clonada after school
i was like i gotta watch it just uh yeah
and honestly i'm you know for me i get
it because you know time is limited
right yeah yeah yeah i'm just a nerd who
just likes doing this and like
if i had because there was actually a
period where
i would drop shows really fast like
maybe in like my teen years or whatever
like early 20s like i was like ah this
is boy i'm gonna stop oh it's three
episodes it's boring i'm gonna stop
right yeah and then i just i kept
dropping stuff over and over and over
again i was like okay i'm gonna start
like finishing stuff even if i start
hating it i'll hate watch it to the end
right yeah yeah yeah and like that well
we're talking a lot about clematis
um
i think you know revisiting you're going
into it after like you know a 14-year
gap or whatever yeah i think the first
like
eight episodes kind of suck like they're
not very good [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean i'm
gonna say that that literally put me off
clan ad yeah like it's very it's very
slow the [ __ ] story is like a
starfish girl i just like i'm just like
i can tell you're like yeah i'd [ __ ]
yeah frequently forgot now i could tell
like they were trying to pull my heart
strings i'm like no yeah
she's awful yeah and then they bring her
back and she's just awful but uh yeah
but then because i stuck with it and
watched it like in the last 10 were like
really good i was like yeah i'm glad
that i like stuck with it yeah which is
kind of tying back to like the whole
reviewing thing yeah um going back to
like obscure
obscure [ __ ] so there was have you seen
have you seen tonkatsu dj agataro yeah
that one's great that's a great show
isn't that obscure though because like
do you know what that is i'm gonna
search that because like they made a lot
of memes of that i remember that show
yeah the because that's such a memey
show yeah yeah so it's like i remember
at one point what is this show
it's a guy who works at a tonkatsu
restaurant and he's like
i wanna make him a dj and he starts
applying the skills that he learned
through making tonkatsu
into djing it's one of the weirdest
shows oh i have seen this one i have not
finished it but i have i have watched it
yeah okay okay that's that's really
weird
this is like i i noticed like you find a
lot of obscure shows i guess through
like the early 2000s era yeah where i
because like i i think
after around like i think it's around
2016 2017 everyone just started watching
everything yeah but there's this like
magical golden period which is between
like it's between the 90s end of the 90s
ova era yeah like the golden age of the
mid-2000s yeah early 2000s there's just
so many [ __ ] shows where it's just
like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah because
there was like a lot of anime being
produced back then compared to like you
know say like the 90s and everything
like that but because of how the
internet was we just didn't have access
to every show like we did now so if like
fan subbers just didn't choose to sub it
then you just wouldn't hear about it at
all yeah and i guess like a lot of the
shows you're saying now just come just
comes from that like comes from that
lost era god it feels weird to call it a
lost era
of the century early 2000's oh my god
see i'm just looking at my
is is this is this your hobby just like
to just like find
your anime to like talk about talking
about it you know yeah i mean connor can
attest like when we met at um the anime
awards
it was like you me uh like miles and
like a couple of people just like you're
just in the lobby just talking about
anime just like have you seen this or do
you know this i fell out my depth pretty
fast
yeah yeah i know that one yeah i know
that one then they said to my shoes i'm
like okay another one and i okay
what the [ __ ]
that was just like crazy though yeah i
mean yeah
everyone had like different levels of
anime knowledge but yeah yeah yeah
everyone was there said something sort
of to do with anime yeah yeah yeah so
it's really interesting it's like going
down like the anime iceberg you know
it's yeah it's like where where are you
on the iceberg yeah my my
main memory of that which is you just
playing love life in the corner while
everyone was just like awkwardly sitting
there but all you could hear
and this guy is just like
and everyone's like
yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
i respected that oh my god yeah what
award did you present at the anime
awards i can't remember me yeah
i don't remember
did you just turn up you're like
yeah
do you remember yours
on yours i remember
i think i did best comedy i think i did
best girl
oh yeah you did you did how how was the
anime awards because i was sad i didn't
get i didn't get to go to that one was
really fun right i mean john yeah
we went to mcdonald's yeah you got to
see like the crunch rolls
donald's yeah we went to the country
office yeah yeah very fancy uh i
remember yeah we went to the really
sketchy mcdonald's in san francisco
that's right yeah
uh because it was after
the after the party
and so we were [ __ ] hungry yeah we
were it was like 11 p.m we were really
hungry and then we're losing yuan's
british slang yeah that's right we're
going through like differences and stuff
yeah and we went to this mcdonald's that
was really really sketchy
yeah yeah like no windows it was like
really dimly lit it was really [ __ ]
weird yeah yeah yeah everyone who came
in was a character
from gta or like a gta character yeah
just downtown l.a yeah
san francisco is scarier than l.a i
think sometimes really yeah well i cause
like i hear stories from like some of
the [ __ ] melin says and i'm like there's
there's no way this is a thing is la
scara or san francisco they're both the
same i don't think either is
particularly scary maybe he's a farm
person maybe yeah i think both are
pretty scary yeah okay yeah to me la is
like it's intense yeah yeah
i get it now when melin says like you
need to be alert like constantly because
like in japan you just like [ __ ] zonk
out okay when you're in [ __ ] japan
then you know like yeah
yeah you're fine like yeah yeah i mean
have any of you been to like i don't
know like
baltimore or detroit or okay are you
you're from michigan right from michigan
yeah so like like i've been to detroit
and you know uh uh my wife grew up in
maryland so i've been to like outside
the inner harbor baltimore like right
those are areas that i'm like this can
be a little what is it like what's the
experience like over there uh
there's definitely areas where like we
shouldn't walk through here
because i think about that about l.a i
just think it's interesting yeah yeah
yeah because i think you should i i
would not feel safe downtown l.a
especially
is disgusting but yeah yeah right
in general yeah yeah
safety is uh
relative right safety
safety is relative where you come from
so earlier you were talking about you
know completing anime completing shows
just
yeah yeah just just so you can put it on
like your list or whatever yeah so would
you like
have you ever like watched anime or
shows at like 1.5 speed or two time
speed absolutely not
that's good okay good yeah
i've actually done it for like a lot of
shows most mostly mostly so
because it is my job right so i have to
let this belief
because
i do it and it's better you drop the
episode or you watch it in 1.5
there are some okay there are some shows
there are some shows where you're just
like i i i kind of like i know what kind
of show this is going to be but i need
to consume it in order to like review it
right
and this is the monster we created
to draw things let people drop things
and so instead of watching it at normal
speed i'm just like just to make sure
i'm going to watch this show at one
point five or two speed just to make
sure that it's actually the show that i
think it's going to be and 99 percent
you have no idea how quickly i can read
subtitles now because of this right like
i literally like it's osmosis right now
whenever i watch subtitles it's
what why did i agree to be on this
someone's watching this at one point
oh god have you watched any like any
youtube videos at 1.5 speed are you just
like yeah i'm i'm a firm believer that
you shouldn't watch videos
in the 1.5 speed like i can't i
physically can't there are occasionally
some youtubers you can you're just not
trying hard enough there are some
youtubers when you put them to 1.5 they
sound like they're talking at a normal
speed which is that's when i need it
yeah because i'm like please i need you
to oh actually no there there is one
youtuber that is a friend of ours that i
watch at 1.5 speed uh sorry john a super
eyebrow
but you know but you just talk so slow
dude
but like john john's someone who i ca
like i
you need to watch at normal speed
because like his his pace like it it
brings like the immersion and the mood
he's trying to set yeah
like videos i'm just like i really want
to watch it but i just don't have the
time right now so i'll just i'll just
like i'll do 1.25 you know just like a
little bit faster so i could just get it
through it a little bit faster i'm the
type of person where if i'm what
listening like someone let's say
someone's put like puts up like a song
from a movie or something yeah yeah and
it's even so slightly
because sometimes it's pitched wrong
because it's like either for copyright
or something like just it's like one
half note because of the speed yeah i'm
like i can't watch this
it distracts me so much yeah this is not
right this isn't right yeah yeah 1.5 or
two times
no
i've never seen a person look more
disgusting please never even
say that to me what are you you're going
to say something next to piss me off
what's next
yeah i mean like are you the type of guy
where you watch something and you need
to like i kind of like
how can i say this you can't
can you watch something casually like in
the background or do you need to be like
sitting down paying attention making
sure that you are in like the mood and
the zone into i have to be watching full
attention because i'm the same yeah
because i have a lot of friends in the
animation industry right and they're
like i watch this show while doing you
know drawing or doing work and i'm like
yeah so you didn't watch it then
i'm not saying you didn't really watch
it yeah you heard a podcast version of
it yeah like i i get like doing that
with like music for example exactly
because it's like you know it's there's
nothing visual you you're only just
using your stereos
but like you know or like with music
videos for example right but it's like
with something like a movie or a tv
series especially when it's anime where
it's like you know subbed for instance
yeah you have to watch it fully because
it's a visual show like it's it's yeah
exactly again you're just watching the
podcast version of it yeah like a
podcast i can listen to while i'm doing
something that's all it's for right yeah
but yeah if you say you watch the show
and you were doing something else the
entire time yeah i'm like okay so you
you didn't really so you didn't watch it
yeah but now i'm like would i rather
someone watch a show
half paying attention or through double
speed
i don't know what's worse
we found the bigger evil
god i don't know so in double speed
yeah
[Music]
you're watching it entirely though
no you're you're not no no okay okay i
am watching inside you're also doing
something no no no no no no no no no i i
can't do that i can't do that i can't do
that like if
the reason i put it on 1.5 or two times
speed is because i cannot watch
something casually like i would love to
be able to you know watch anime and be
able to like write about it um stuff my
job and also be able to like do
something else especially if it's like a
[ __ ] show but like i'm the type of guy
who who needs to pay attention and i
need to be watching it but sometimes
there are just there's like a lot of
[ __ ] out there man there's a lot of
mediocrity out there sometimes i just
want to get through
get through like the mediocre shows so i
can movies like no no you can't drop
them
like what
double standards
no no it's it's
it's it's it's because talking about
anime is my job right it's because like
i i need to i need to watch it in order
to have like the informed opinion that i
want to and you know sometimes there is
a certain show that gets better
i'm just surprised you can consume it at
two-time speed
why because it's like
[Music]
so many reasons
okay i gotta ask
are you a big video game guy do you play
a lot of video games uh not as much as i
used to but i do so what's the opinion
on uh skipping cutscenes
on the on your first play uh yeah
absolutely not
i skipped like all cutscenes
i'm also a voice sector
so you're just like bullring boring i
don't wanna just skip to the gameplay
yeah
that's exactly what he did you don't
know what's going on
just like shoot shoot jump jump jump a
lot of the time yeah
we're gonna have our first guest
we're gonna have a first guest walk off
we're gonna make history today
which one's worse give me the cutscenes
at least he's watching yeah
i love the thanos stream of like when
you get to the end boss and then like
you took everything from me i don't even
know who you are
that's literally him playing every
single video
what are some of your favorite video
games
let's let's let's move to the topic of
doing something cutscenes so something a
little lighter right
let me guess are you a kingdom hearts
fan
oh no really well you're a disney fan
though uh yeah but i like good games
i mean i played uh one one is bad i
played chain memories i played two
i played 3.4 358 over two days
unfortunately that one's terrible that
one sucks here i haven't played anything
past that yeah i think they're like i
like i actually like chain of memories
really yeah that's the one that's weird
but it has like kind of deck building in
it so i i like that right right um but
uh
and i wouldn't call myself a kingdom
hearts fan though right i didn't play
past a certain point
um what are some games that you do like
them uh i love paper mario
mario yeah yeah i love bioshock uh okay
final fantasy nine uh is my favorite
uh i like seven a lot too um
i mean i grew up with a lot of nintendo
stuff so yeah mario i love i do love
good jrpgs like you know i loved like
persona 5 dragon quest 11 hell you've
been trying to get him to play
personally
i've i've been scared i've been scared
talking in it
he's just gonna do like a [ __ ] speech
every time i skip cuts i was like aren't
you a voice actor why are you skipping
the cutscene because i'm like hey i just
because i do it doesn't mean i want to
watch the cutscene
because a game for me is just i just
want to play i don't wanna i don't wanna
story nonsense
connor what if everyone in the you voice
in the game is everyone skipped all your
dialogues i wouldn't mind they have the
right they have the right to do it
they don't have the right
they have the right it's only the second
time only the second only
when i stream games i try not to do it
but sometimes i have like reflex to do
it and then i'm so sorry chad i didn't
mean to do that
he's not sorry he's not sorry
yeah yeah no i uh i have a let's play
channel and we're doing uh paper mario
and my co-host my good friend jay was
like skipping through the dialogue and i
was like you gotta [ __ ] stop you got
it
and we do it like months in advance and
so like when they came out all the
comments were like stop skipping through
the dialogue and i was like i was right
yeah
especially paper mario because the dial
looks so chunky i know it's so charming
right uh
i'm like i'm gonna kill you
i'm absolutely gonna be we should never
do a let's play no no absolutely not oh
unless like connect full yeah yeah
exactly or pac-man
yeah do you find that if you're voicing
something does that enhance in the
experience for you or does that like
mean that you can't watch it or you
can't play it anymore like um
it doesn't really have any effect effect
for me like i actually have not played
any of the games i'm in oh really yeah
is that is that out of pure coincidence
or coincidence okay uh i think the one
that just got announced today
fire emblem warriors three hopes that
one i probably will play because i
actually uh like you like
i love three houses that i'm gonna play
and i love musso games yeah um you
should ask about his fireball experience
i played three houses yeah he completed
it one route well he completed one route
and then he and then he dropped it did
you watch the cutscenes
i was confused a lot of the time
you know would like because there's a
whole i'll spoil it for
three houses i'll give you like three
seconds yeah so you know how there's
like a big betrayal yeah i was like
really confused at like one point
because i was like wait why am i
fighting home because i skipped the
cutscenes
i just like the strategy elements of the
the gameplay i thought that was fun so
for you they're like i just like these
nondescript anime chess pieces to move
around yep i don't know what any of them
why why they're here or what they're
doing but they they go slash slash i
like it i felt like i learned the
character through the combat styles you
know like because a lot of them their
combat styles reflect their character i
think um
uh but there was also like the part when
i went to school and i was so [ __ ]
bored oh you would have hate persona 5
yeah it was like it was like i do this
amazing gameplay section where i was
like damn that was damn this guy said
these things throwing hands dude and
then i go back to this school i gotta
talk to people for like 40 minutes and
fish
that's literally just like that
you just described
it
that's so [ __ ] boring why are you
making me do this let me let me just
play the gameplay you are playing the
game talking to the characters playing
the game yeah the game that's part of
the game do you like characters
or or plots i do i do for me it's like i
i love stories in movies in video games
i just want that pure gameplay that's
all i want from games he has goopy
goblin gamer brain i yeah so that's why
the majority games i play uh like
competitive games if i wasn't streaming
i wouldn't do any of these like i would
never played inscription but i'm so glad
i did inscription was so fun
what's inscription oh my god is this
amazing uh indie game by uh uh who's it
called the guys made a bunch of other
amazing games yeah i don't remember the
names
really talented game dev uh and it's
it's how would you describe the
description i actually uh didn't finish
it because uh but from it's basically
like an escape room combined with like a
deck building game
like you're in like a creepiest like
cabin and you're locked in and then like
you're trying to advance through this
game of like cards like right and um
like you slowly start unlocking things
yeah yeah yeah the gameplay and that
the visual style completely changes
three times wow see i don't actually
don't know that part
no that's okay yeah yeah it's really
cool is it does it have a story oh yeah
and uh i mean i i had to read the story
and i had to pay attention because i was
oh horrible
i was streaming and i can't skip the
realize everyone gets pissed off
rightfully exactly yeah
i enjoyed that story though but i think
it's that's good if i give it a shot
i'll do it but if i was playing it alone
i wouldn't do it and i'd have that i'd
have it so you have to force yourself to
play story based games on stream
otherwise you are going to skip the
story yeah most definitely yeah remember
remember when we were trying to get him
to play 13 sentinels oh that sounds like
a nightmare that would be a nightmare oh
no i remember we we said yeah connor you
should play 13 sentinels i think on the
podcast he said yeah oh can i just skip
the cutscenes and i'm like that game is
all cut
attorney uh i have never been interested
nice attorney i know why no
the style never appealed to
it's a good game yeah yeah i liked um or
like duncan rolfe
but you skipped all the cutscenes yeah
so for you it was just like a [ __ ] it
was like a brain age game
it was like
you're like who's that guy what's his
deal i don't know i don't know
it's it's weird because it doesn't take
away any of my enjoyment of games yeah
like i still well i'm happy for you i
liked three houses i had a fun time i
just wish i could skip a lot of more
stuff easier you know
[Music]
i liked it though i love the the cool
like gameplay i'm just gonna find out oh
yeah also i i only smell food i don't
actually
what i do
when
yeah i mean uh what are some other games
that uh i've played that i enjoyed that
i skipped all the cartoons did you what
about metal gear revengeance because i
feel like okay that was like you
couldn't like
it wouldn't even like even if i wanted
to i couldn't press the skip button it
was so enthralling like all those cut
scenes were just like orgasmic
that was a good game but it was like a
five-hour game it was ten hours
yeah but also i mean that was so funny
that was a movie that was a movie with
quick time events yeah yeah yeah so i
mean i mean that's like a lot of kojima
that's most kojima games no
i have not however you know that
cutscenes are also like little movies in
a game
a movie with occasional button pressing
it's like if it's like if your dvd kept
freezing well like like to me like to me
when i get to the gut like the cut scene
and everything like that like i feel
like it's
the feeling you get when you get to the
cutscene or the story portions in the
video game is like different from
watching a movie because like i feel
like i earned it you know you know like
i i feel like progressing through a
video game story is so much more
satisfying than progressing through a
movie story right because like you watch
a movie and you're just there to enjoy
the story with a video game if it's like
there's immersion yeah there's the
merger you really feel like damn i
[ __ ] earned this story man it feels
good for me it's like i don't know what
it's going on with my my brain but
if it's just like a normal game where
it's like oh if i can like one attempt
everything then i don't feel like i've
earned it i'm like yeah i just did it
first time easy because because to me to
me like there are some games that i i i
have a hard time finishing games right
because i get through like the gameplay
loop i enjoy that and then it's like you
get to like that 60 to 70 percent and it
kind of i feel that yeah yeah yeah and
then it kind of just becomes the same
all over again except you have 30
percent of the game left to play right
if there is not a story i am not
finishing that game or if i'm not
investing in that story there is no way
i'm like
i get that i get that yeah and you find
that with especially a lot of jrpgs
where
like because jrpgs are so long you get
to kind of near end game and then that's
when that's when it you hit like a wall
it's also it's also that thing with
jrpgs where it's like you get to that
like sixty seventy percent part and then
you're like oh you know you get busy or
whatever right like yeah yeah
and then you don't play it
and then you come back and you're like
what was happening again yeah
all right you know what i'll just start
from the beginning
one of the only jrpgs i've ever played
uh these guys know but i've never played
uh like blue dragon
oh uh
a little bit but i never got far that
was i watched it i've never even played
that what made you watch all the
cutscenes in that and not literally
every other game you've ever so you know
when you're at that age where you can
only have like three games yeah a year
and then you're like well gotta get my
mileage out so you like milked it you're
like all right i'll watch these cut
scenes because
i need more hours to fill it so that i
don't have to go beg my mum for another
game
yeah it's like you know when you hit a
game stop and you would get like i don't
know if they did they're using game
stuff in the uk they did this we can get
like three games for like 20 bucks if
they were pre-owned oh yeah so i would
pick up like any game that looked
remotely cool and it was normally the
ones that were like anime looking turned
out those are the games that i actually
liked least
yeah
there's so much
characters here
it's so long
game writers crying right
game writers animators voice actors all
crying yeah yeah yeah well he is a voice
actor
i don't feel if for someone to skip it
i'm like would you would you skip a game
dialogue if you were in it or would you
just skip to your dialogue maybe i'd
listen to it the first time if you're
like cool i remember doing this skip
skip
okay um to go back you asked before
about stuff that i'm in yeah um so games
i haven't played anything but shows i've
actually watched okay that i'm in and
that doesn't
bother me in fact uh
i wouldn't say like enhances it but
oftentimes i'm like
oh like this is the whole like
because um
uh context context exactly like for like
like i i play kage in racking ranking of
kings right and i only did the kage
parts right
and so when i went in
you know sometimes have you guys seen
the rankings yeah i've seen i haven't
watched it yet okay i've seen a couple
of episodes yeah there'll be part you've
seen the whole thing yeah there'll be
parts where like a character comes back
and they'll like they don't have an eye
anymore right and you're like i'm like
what the hell happened
because it happened like it's somewhere
on some other that's the sea dog va
experience
so uh when i finally sat down to i
watched ranking kings like last month
right uh and i actually was like should
i watch this sub your dub knows
i was thinking about it because i
usually watch stuff subbed yeah i was
like uh i'll watch it dub because you
know let's see how it all fit in yeah
yeah yeah it was actually a really good
dub like all like uh bias aside like
everyone had a really good job but it
was enjoyable to be like oh like
this is the whole picture now like right
like i recognize all the scenes that i'm
in but now i'm seeing like what all the
other characters were doing and right
okay like memento
kinda yeah i mean it's funny like in
when i was recording ranking of kings i
chose to not watch
as it was airing right some of the
actors did some of the actors were like
i want to like watch japanese yeah i was
like i'm not going to do it because i
don't want to know what they sound like
my character doesn't know oh okay okay
if a character runs in and i'm like i
don't know what happened i have not seen
what happened to this character yeah
yeah yeah i can
like you know react a little more
naturally too right right that's right
um so something like that or like um
like retsuko was like another one where
i watched it and
got to see the full
the full because there's a whole
storyline in yeah even if you've watched
gretzko yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you yeah
season three there's a whole height of
storyline i have no part in dubbing so
like i was like oh that's what's going
on with the height of stuff right right
i was only in the agretzko side
do you find with villain voices i like
watching it because
i feel like i don't if you're watching
if you're dubbing it or working with
these characters you're getting the
script you don't know the character's
full intention so i like as when you're
a villain you get to
watch all of it or read all of it you're
like okay this is what i'm working
towards this is what my goal was so when
i go in the start i know what kind of
energy i'm going with and what i'm what
i'm really going towards but i guess
yeah when you're like kind of just a cog
in the machine or a protagonist and it's
all happening reaction yeah that would
help yeah how do you get like the
context of each scene then if a director
will explain it oh okay so like the
director will explain stuff like okay so
this is what happened
this and this and this but you still
like there's still tons of stuff you
don't like you just trust me
you trust that they know and like you
you sort of have to be in the in the
moment of the character basically yeah
yeah yeah um do you ever have a take
when you're just like that's not the
take but they take it they use it anyway
um
no i usually because i'm just [ __ ]
bangers
i only need one baby because usually i
know when it's like not the one right
like uh
i often find for me
it's not the right take if it's just
like a
more of a technical thing like
enunciation or like a stumble yeah yeah
than than an acting choice yeah like
usually i agree with whatever they
choose yeah um but sometimes it is
interesting like in um especially when
you're doing video games and you're
doing like hundreds of lines right and
you know uh it'll just be like you do
like it like an abc take where it's like
three different takes yeah and then they
just go okay uh b and it's like i don't
know which one b was out of the three
takes i did so when you watch the final
thing you're like oh these are the takes
that they chose like interesting that
can be kind of that that's also the fun
part of like
watching something that you're in i'm
like oh like these are the ones they
chose in the end and you know that kind
of thing yeah
so when i was dubbing this one anime one
time uh the preview they've been given i
think from japan was so low res
but i couldn't even see the lip flaps oh
[ __ ] okay i was like
i'm like i'm like i actually asked him
like did i match it i i don't know did
it ever happened to you or
uh where it was so low-res yeah yeah on
the monitor where they gave it to you
it was like 100p
and then the character was off in the
side talking i'm like
how am i supposed to time it
help me out
um i haven't had that problem here's a
little dirty secret of buying uh
i don't look at the flaps yeah i
realized after doing it a few times i
just stopped looking yeah
because usually the scripts are so well
written to match
that
uh you don't actually need to like
usually if i listen to the japanese yeah
uh watch the scene once
and kind of play the line in my head i
know the rough timing or even just
knowing oh this one it's kind of a slow
slower delivery yeah i can just go
naturally and
95 or 90 of the time it just fits right
because they've written it so
succinctly yeah already that it
naturally fits the engineers are also
wizards the engineers are amazing
it'll be like not fitting they'll be
like oh i think we make it fit just uh
oh it's perfect it literally fits and it
sounds perfect exactly [ __ ] it's like
these these dudes are insane yeah
they're invaluable yeah yeah so i heard
like an audio engineer is like your best
friend oh yeah oh yeah
i swear like most of the lines i did was
like a little bit off and then like oh
yeah
when i did my first anime i was so like
oh i gotta make sure like i can match it
perfectly like i was so like intimidated
by it yeah yeah uh and then i realized
oh no they'll just tell you like if it's
yeah and you just do it again they're
not gonna be like pissed off at you yeah
they're what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
like oftentimes it's like oh the script
is just oh we gotta change this word or
like you know like things like that like
stuff that's out of your control anyway
right right right yeah well thank you
very much for coming on the show or
should i say sorry for coming on the
show
yeah uh i i i you made enemies today i
definitely definitely learned some new
things about you guys
can i take any of it back
but board games don't have cutscenes
right so that's
the equivalent of you skipping cutscenes
would be like i'm reading the
instructions and you go what
definitely i'll just i'll just learn as
i go
you actually just called me out
i like to play the game and i'm like oh
okay that makes sense wait you don't
listen to instructions when you i i
listen but then i'm like it's normally a
lot of information and the way for me to
process it is to do like a round i'm
like this is okay
what he's saying is he hears her but he
doesn't actually take it yeah i'm
actually the same in that way i feel
like i learned better by experiencing
something rather than someone like that
that makes sense because you know even
hearing a bunch a load of text is not
gonna make sense but once you're doing
stuff yeah yeah yeah really basic
concept sometimes you're like what and
then you just see it and you're like oh
yeah yeah very very simple
[ __ ] idiot yeah yeah
yeah but hey look at all these patrons
though oh my god wow look at all these
people support the show
i saw them right there yeah actually i
skipped them sorry
i i only i only look at patreon credits
with their double spa
but hey if you want to support the show
then go to our patreon patreon.com also
follow us on twitter send us some memes
on the subreddit and if you hate our
face listen to us on spotify and uh hey
i mean we don't have to tell you go go
check out someone's stuff is there
something you want to shout out anything
uh i mean yeah youtube twitter i guess
tic tac now just like pro zd he's not
bands p-r-o-z-d just google that you'll
find everything on there yeah yeah yeah
links in the description check it out
yeah thank you so much for coming on and
i'm sorry
we're all sorry at least joey didn't
piss you off yeah
anyway we'll see you guys next week
[Music]
you